you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from the youth games of 1976
on the white end 18 year old Armenian
sim bat laputan a player who was about
master strength for this game he earned
his international master title in 1982
and Grandmaster title in 1984 his
opponent 13 year-old garry kasparov
still shy of his master rank he earned
that in 1978 and as one might have
expected tracked very quickly towards
his Grandmaster title earning that in
1980 this game a nice window into the
young tactical mind of Garry Kasparov
let's have a look opening why's it is a
king's indian defense in opening
Kasparov would go on to play throughout
his whole career variation is a mich
with F 3 an aggressive system certainly
can be an aggressive system this is
securing the bishop post on e3 how can
it turn aggressive put your bishop on e3
Queen on D to form this battery in some
order Queen side castles h4 dark square
bishop sustained go right after the
black Kings throw it's not to be in this
game it is black who goes on the
offensive beginning with just a touch of
pressure on the weakest Square and
White's camp d4 that is a hole so some
defense is necessary over that Bishop e3
may be tempting to immediately strike at
d4 with e5 currently the only pawn break
in the position for black
it is not well-timed however 'if I've
can be met with d5 and after Knight d4
this is not a good sequence not because
light can win upon not a wise choice for
white to give up their better bishop for
that night but rather because white can
play Knight to e2 and ask the knight
what are you doing in my house the
knight cannot be maintained and what
exactly has been accomplished with this
sequence by black it remains to be seen
in fact black has expedited White's
development and white also enjoys a nice
static advantage pawn established on d5
some space
'if I've something to keep in mind just
not yet in this game a six rook b8
introducing an additional pawn break EE
five and now there is b5
both try and chip away at White's pawn
trio from here a little bit awkward to
complete development on the Kings side
certainly you don't want to go to the
edge with the night at the Knights
favorite square is taken away with the
pawn going to e2 this masks the bishop
from seeing b5 maybe black plays b5 here
some other order if the bishop goes here
with this in mind next well the queen is
not seeing d4 this may spark a Knight d7
move unleashing the bishop and only then
following up with e5 and it may be the
case that a knight can be maintained on
d4
okay in this game we have white doesn't
commit with either kingside minor piece
rook b1 and then b4 looking to grab some
space on the clean side certainly looks
menacing it certainly looks strong for
white but where is white week where is
white deficient with this plan what is
white neglecting kingside development
black is castled white is still a three
Tempe away from getting castled it is at
this point where black now welcomes
exchanges hits at this stage with e5
let's see how things are a little bit
different after d5 Knight d4
white follows at this point with Knight
to e2 but I want to highlight a nice
tactic to be familiar with suppose white
wants to get rid of this strong bishop
this Fein Quetta Bishop still looking
for maybe an attack like this what is
the issue with this move it's true that
white in this scenario with the rook Rd
on b1 will not be going clean side it
would be completely inconsistent to go
Queen side here having moved the B pawn
the rook on b1 okay what is the issue
with Bishop to h6 feel free to pause the
video okay important tactic to be
familiar with Knight takes e4 hitting
the Queen and opening the Queen's eyes
to this check this is not just the win
of upon by the game but the game well
Queen takes bishop this is already a
minus 3 evaluation so there is no Bishop
to h6 its Knight to eat - and now the
follow up c5 looking to cement this
knight in there so how should white
react to this might be tempting to grab
on c5 and say my rooks eyes are opened
and thank you so much for giving me a
connected past upon at the same time
black would be saying thank you for
allowing my knight to be maintained on
d4 it's going to be a great bother and
if you ever get rid of it I too will
then have a connected past pawn so what
does white do white captures on c6 takes
this pawn on for some recapture this
variation this sequence here is giving
up a pawn black is giving up upon but in
the process lines files diagonals are
opening up and black is preparing for a
tactical shot we are at this point how
to follow up from here what do we have
in the game c5 creating more pawn
tension more open lines B takes c5 and
what to do at this stage move 16 black
to move what would you do
okay here we go I must admit that this
is one of the first moves that crossed
my mind
and a quick reason I assigned for that
was isn't it a good idea to demote the
knight you know just force it back to
its home Square no
13-year old Gary snaps the pawn on e4
still with this ID in mind I highlighted
it in a different scenario with the
bishop on h6 but we're seeing another
instance where Knight takes on e4 is
there and I also want to point out the
importance of not taking on b1 first so
we're gonna look back to this position
here and see why taking on this square
first and then taking on e4 is not good
and why taking on e4 straight away is
good the move played in the game what do
you do
well if you take with the night you lose
the ruck
so you got to take with the poem and now
in the game comes Queen age for the
reply at this stage is not best what
white plays is g3 considered best is
Bishop to f2 and I'm highlighting this
variation because it's something that
thirteen-year-old Kasparov had to have
calculated he needed to know what to do
in this scenario black to move what
would you do and reply to Bishop f2 ok
the only move here that maintains
equality any other move and white would
be better the only move that works here
for black is to take on c3 and so we are
seeing a point the main point in keeping
tension between the rooks black wants to
have this Bishop takes Knight move
available in reply to Bishop f2 so how
would play follow from here best play is
liquidating like so Queens are exchanged
and we enter this double Bishop ending
reading as equal something that he
needed to calculate was this Bishop 2f
to move at this stage right here how is
it different
if black first exchanges rooks and only
then takes on e4 and then gives the
Czech well Bishop 2f - there is no
Bishop takes Knight and while Queen
efore queen takes e4 at this stage may
seem tempting there's a way out for
white by simply castling Knight is
defended and this bishop is indifferent
is defended indirectly Queen takes
bishop would be met with a nice skewer
Queen takes Queen thank you for the rook
with Czech and only then will I take
your Queen if you lost count
White's up a rook with this variation so
how important it is to keep this tension
keep white in a state where this Bishop
takes Knight move is available Knight
takes e4 crushing move
well the best move I should say Queen h4
in the game what was played not bishop
f2 g3 and only now do we have rook takes
rook King to f2 now whether or not
Kasparov still had this position in his
calculations did he work this one out
I don't know this next move there's an
only move here that maintains an
advantage for black every other move and
white is winning
what is the saving move here what is the
best move for black in this position
note what's going on first of all Queen
is hit rook is hit what are you gonna do
about that
black to move what would you do okay
here we go best move move played in the
game rook to b2 what you should be
looking to do in this position as black
is move your queen get out of harm's way
and throw a check but there's no good
checks no no no I mean what do you do no
good checks they're all covered rook b2
says you take my queen I take your queen
that's what happened in the game suppose
the Queen takes the rook well now we see
the power of this dark square bishop if
Queen takes rook Bishop takes Bishop
check and there's no good solution for
white I'll just show a couple variations
this one's simple if King G - it's a
matin
with check and checkmate
and if King goes back home we would have
Bishop takes Knight and then Queen takes
pawn crushing
one of these two will fall no saving
them this is not working
that's a pinned bishop so any other
variation not really keep in mind if
you're not taking the Queen right now
black is up the exchange so what is
played pawn takes Queen rook takes Queen
it's getting simplified we're inching it
entering a technical phase now it
certainly was tactical there in the
middle game it's a technical phase now
King III rook c2 King d3 how to react at
this stage another pop quiz in this
ending what would you do black to move
okay here we go
rook takes night
and then pawn takes pawn
why is this best well consider an
alternative right if you play rook be
one light replies and wins a point let's
say the other variation is to give up a
point give up five get three give four
this is what we have in the game
to this simplified position where it is
clearly better for black materially
balanced but positionally superior why
better structure better bishop right a
nice pond island of three all-white
ponds are isolated black has the better
bishop black has the initiative throwing
the first punch also throwing light on
their heels has to crawl up into a ball
has to defend efore more pressure on e4
more defense and a nice follow up rookie
5 and mobilizing the pawn and something
more there's now some lateral movement
targeting these half-dead pawns what do
you do here in the game a 4
this allows f5 move played in the game
King daddy - it's true this prevents f5
f5 is not good here but there's rock h5
and these pawns are falling and this one
is going to follow it's check so what is
played a four
f-five
going so white tries to get some
activity
Brooke b1 Bishop takes e4 this is a
passer and it runs fast
rook b64 rook takes a f3 Bishop f5
looking to get here push the pawn
through check King 2 D 2 f2 nearby and
rook to e1 Bishop e2 prevents that
but this Bishop has responsibilities so
black just tries to deflect it Bishop to
g4 you take my bishop I get a queen
white gets out of the way
rook to e1 behind the pond and a nice
interference move on this move 36 Bishop
to f5 once more bishop can't take and
what are you doing about f1 equals queen
next no good solution so what's tried is
a5 couple ways of many ways to win from
here
this one seems very clean what was
played in the game is Bishop takes
Bishop just a little bit of calculation
after rook takes pawn it appears that
White's going to get one of these two
necks but that's not the case after rook
to f1 white resigns
my bishop I take your rook and if you
take my rook I take the rook so white is
not going to win a piece this is
completely winning for Team black now I
did carry it out I was a little bit
curious of what would the cleanest
approach would be in this ending I want
to have a look at this the the variation
I ended up going forward with ended up
into some pawn race both sides cleaning
it should never get to that point I was
thinking to myself I'll just run up here
and you only ever move the bishop here
once a seven to a eight is actually a
threat but absolute cleanest in my
opinion is to get the bishop immediately
on the diagonal not just to stop the
pawn but to stop the white king from
even thinking about hunting the c5 pump
this one key move kills all counter play
on the spot a nice wall is formed and
from here it is smooth King just vacuums
up the H pawns and yeah pick your
favorite way to Queen at that stage
anyhow
didn't get to that point after rook to
f1 white resigned so very nice play it's
true the setup that white went with rook
B 1 and B 4 wasn't optimal but still a
nice illustration of how to chip away in
the center open lines diagonals and that
Knight takes e4 move something to
certainly be familiar with in multiple
scenarios so if we have a look at tale
the tape on this game see how accurate
they're playing at this age
thirteen-year-old kasparov not bad right
looking at the inaccuracies mistakes and
blunders we have three and accuracies
one mistakes zero blunders by team white
and thirteen year-old Gary Kasparov one
in accuracy no mistakes no blunders
average sent upon loss for each 21 and
12 anyhow as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you